[Music]
look at me
come on let's talk about this buddy i'll
mastered advanced and quicker than
twitch
watch out for the speed
oh no
later
[Music]
175 miles per hour okay
you get it buddy
you can back off now hater i am mean
parrots stream it on disney plus
hey mater wanna race
well come on
look at you all charged up the race but
i don't have a chance of getting out
come on
buddy just letting you know i'm gonna be
gone because i'm heading back east to go
to my sister's wedding wait a minute you
have a sister whoa goggles of mine man
must be ages since you've seen her what
if i'd go with you really let's make it
a road trip
there's thousands of things to see
which is the tiniest little taste of
death
oh dear mother
i'm guessing this is the beginning of
something great you got that right
we wander the backroads this is so cool
make new friends
where are you guys headed
i gotta rinse off this whole baggage
whoa
look at you
what about me
can't mess with perfection
i spy with my little eye
two quackity kitty cars
points for pageantry
[Music]
this is not what i expected
all the bumps along the road
that's what makes life worth
[Music]
living buddy
[Music]
i love these i don't know come on look
you picked the last stop world's largest
tire maze mcqueen mater mcqueen mater
mcqueen
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign